as if the entire worldwide embarrassment
that is the Trump Ukraine Fiasco could
get any more embarrassing right now
we've learned that Donald Trump's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani is back in
Ukraine right now right he's in Ukraine
right now and what is Rudy doing back in
Ukraine he is talking once again to
former prosecutors that were part of how
this entire scandal started in the first
place look at what Giuliani is doing as
per the New York Times Tuesday he met
with a former Ukrainian prosecutor in
Budapest this is yuriy lutsenko that
name if you've been watching the
impeachment inquiry hearings should ring
a bell because it has come up dozens of
times during those hearings Wednesday he
went to Kiev or Kiev as we are now told
is the Ukrainian pronunciation went to
keep Ukraine to meet with more Ukrainian
prosecutors including the infamous
Viktor Shokan who is almost at the
center of this entire controversy the
reason why Rudy is back in the region
back in Ukraine meeting with these
people now he's supposedly gathering
information to be part of a documentary
series for a right-wing media outlet
meant to promote Trump and to defend
Trump against the case for impeachment
what a convenient trip for Rudy Giuliani
right imagine you're running impeachment
hearings centered around Trump and his
associates using Ukraine to try to smear
Joe Biden in a bribery extortion scandal
and you say ok you know who we should
really bring in let's bring in Rudy
Giuliani he should testify let's get in
touch with Rudy we did you know what
turns out he can't come to the hearings
because he's in Ukraine right now
meeting with the exact same people
asking for information that can be used
in a right-wing media piece to argue
that there is no case for impeachment
against Donald Trump hearings about Rudy
possibly committing or organising crimes
to help the president sorry he can't
make it he's tied up back in Ukraine
possibly committing crimes or organising
crimes to help the president under the
guise of he's now a TV producer I guess
working on some right-wing media
documentary
meant to defend Donald Trump and you
know what we really shouldn't be
surprised by this remember that when
about I think it was six months ago
Donald Trump was interviewed by George
Stephanopoulos on ABC News and George
Stephanopoulos said to him mr. president
after everything that's happened with
Russia after the Muller probe this that
all this different stuff if Russia came
to you with dirt on opponents for 2020
or China came to you with dirt on
opponents for 2020 would you go to the
FBI or would you would you accept it and
Trump said yeah I'd at least look into
it go to the FBI now probably not but I
would at least look into what they were
bringing me and if I were them if I was
as immoral as they are I would probably
be doing the same thing because there
have been no consequences if you were
Trump and you see well so far I've
gotten away with everything sure some of
my old friends are in prison but I'm
fine
I would probably assume impeachments
going nowhere
likely accurate and that means I still
have to figure out how to win in 2020
dispatch Rudy back to Ukraine except the
dirt from Russia except dirt from China
at this point I would hope that
authorities are watching Rudy Giuliani's
movements which actually leads me to the
next question was it that great of an
idea to have him leave the country in
the sense that his two henchmen left
Parnas and Igor Froman were grabbed by
authorities arrested and indicted as
they were heading to Europe on one-way
plane tickets
Giuliani might be close behind them or
he might never see consequences at all
we just don't know because when someone
is in that second justice system when
you're in the justice system for what
are effectively the American oligarchs
not everybody else you actually it
becomes harder to predict whether you'll
you'll ever be held accountable for your
actions at all so Rudy back in Ukraine
it sounds stranger than fiction but
that's the reality if this were a
screenplay it wouldn't be believable it
would be thrown onto the cutting room
floor it happens to be real life let me
know what you think about Rudy in
Ukraine I'm on Twitter at D Pakman or
leave a reply if you're watching on
YouTube today's program is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blink
Asst it's amazing it's an app for your
phone tablet or web browser and what
they do is they take nonfiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankest one recent one is a Robert
Rice's new book the common good also
bunk by Kevin Young useful in preparing
me for the pseudo-science miniseries
that we're producing and if you are a
David Pakman show viewer or listener you
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube use the link in the
video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n